[Michigan Tuberculosis Association: Theodore Werle, Executive Secretary, presents]
[Peter Borik: The Story of the Tragedy he
Brought his Family]
[Scenario: Wm Kulsea, Narrator: Bob Clayton, Donald O. Buell: Director of Dramatics, Michigan State College.]
[Cast: Agnes... June Merz, Clara... Frances
Joyner, Mrs. Borik... Mary Philips, John...Joe Davidson]
[Dedicated to the fight against tuberculosis]
[Narrator:] The story of Agnes and Clara Borik
and their family could happen in your town,
right next door to you...it could happen to
the rich man and to
the poor man.
The office worker or the farmer, a white man
or a negro. It could happen to the young,
and it could happen to the aged. It could
happen to anyone.
It is the story of a willful man who refused
to believe the truth. Because he stubbornly
and perversely rejected the truth, he brought
tragedy to those
closest to him.
He turned a deaf ear to experienced men of
medicine who sought to help him in his fight
against tuberculosis.
Instead, he chose to rely on the advice of
charlatans and quacks. It is the story of
Peter Borik and the heartaches he brought
his daughters, Agnes and
Clara.
The story opens on a tender note, for Clara
and Johnny Carson, a young farmer who manages
the Borik farm in his spare time, are in love.
They hope to be
married soon. Johnny is her childhood sweetheart.
His regular job, before he took over operation
of the Borik farm, was driving a milk truck
for a large dairy company nearby. He still
does this when he is
able.
Now however, Peter Borik is bedridden most
of the time, and unable to work. Johnny and
Clara, unaware of what the future holds for
them, face life happily,
secure in their love.
Hardworking Mrs. Borik, Peter's wife, lives
for her children alone. A kind, yielding woman,
she is resigned to a life of drudgery, and
ever-constant fear
that Clara and Agnes, and perhaps Johnny,
might fall victim to the disease that Peter
Borik carries.
It's time for lunch, and Johnny has been invited
to eat with the family. Peter cannot leave
his bed. He will not go to a sanatorium. He
does not believe
tuberculosis is catching.
He believes he can get well by staying in
bed. He wants to be near his neighbors so
they can drop in and see him. He likes Mrs.
Borik's cooking.
He wants to be home so he can call his wife
or his daughters at any time of the day or
night. The father's absence at meal time is
evident. But his
influence, both physical and spiritual, is
felt by the entire family every time they
eat.
The door beyond the kitchen stove leads to
his room. From that room he can hear the familiar
voices of his family. At one time he was in
a sanatorium. He was
not a cooperative patient.
He felt there were too many restrictions.
That he did not feel sick. He left against
medical advice. And since doctors cannot force
patients to remain in a
sanatorium, he could not be stopped.
When he left the sanatorium, he left behind
the proper medical care, professional nursing
attention, and the rest routine which is so
essential to the
tuberculosis patient. Through his ignorance,
he left behind all hope, and brought home
a disease which was to bring immeasurable
sorrow to his family.
Peter's presence in the Boriks' household
has not changed the homemaking routine, although
it should have, to ensure protection for the
family.
Dishes used to serve his food are mixed with
those used by the rest of the family. His
bed linen goes in with the family laundry.
The handkerchiefs he uses
contain sputum, which is contaminated with
tuberculosis germs.
The germs spread from person-to-person and
cause tuberculosis. Peter refuses to believe
this simple fact. Like measles, chicken pox
or scarlet fever,
tuberculosis is contagious.
Except for Peter Borik, the Borik family looks
healthy. They feel well. They don't think
they can catch Peter's disease. They don't
know a person may have
tuberculosis for three years and never have
any symptoms.
In recent weeks, Peter Borik's increasingly
bad condition has intensified his stubborn
streak. He talks to his family only in irritable
commands. His raucous
coughing has increased.
The room behind the kitchen stove has become
a self-imposed cell, from which he bars time-tried
methods of tuberculosis cure. His failing
condition is
reflected in his lack of appetite.
Each day he leaves more and more food untouched
on the plate, which Mrs. Borik serves him
three times a day.
But tuberculosis workers know that Peter Borik
left the sanatorium against the advice of
physicians. They have been watching his case
ever since he acted
against the advice of specialists in the field
of tuberculosis cure and prevention.
Now they hope to convince him to return to
the sanatorium. Ever alert for cases such
as these, tuberculosis workers are certain
that Peter Borik will return
in order to protect his wife and daughters.
Courteous and professional, the tuberculosis
worker visits the Borik household. This job
requires tact, for she does not want to frighten
Peter Borik back
into the sanatorium.
She must convince him and Mrs. Borik that
he is spreading tuberculosis to his family
and friends. That he'll be able to receive
visitors frequently in the
sanatorium.
But Mrs. Borik will have none of this. She
is too familiar with the wrath of her husband
and with his ideas of sanatoriums.
Mrs. Borik keeps the visit of the tuberculosis
worker a secret, both from Peter Borik and
from her children.
That's why Johnny and Clara go ahead with
plans to get married. Each new day brings
to them new happiness as they plan for the
future.
They are ignorant of the cloak of disease
that is enveloping the Borik household and
their lives. For how long can the human body
stand up under the strain
of bombardment of the tuberculosis germs?
These two youths, vigorous and gay, appear
to be happy and healthy as they await the
day of their marriage. But are they healthy?
The tuberculosis germ has
used them for targets.
Back in the Borik household, they have been
exposed for months to the germs discharged
by Peter Borik. Is one or both to be a victim?
Perhaps they had come
in contact with tuberculosis by touching an
article contaminated by Peter Borik.
In the spring, Johnny and Clara are married.
Peter Borik is too ill to attend the church
ceremony, but unknown to all, the mark of
his willfulness is with
them.
It is a threat to their happiness that could
have been avoided if Peter had gone to the
sanatorium some time before. In fact, if Peter
had listened to sound
medical advice, or if his wife had acted upon
the suggestion of the tuberculosis worker,
he might have been cured by the time the wedding
took place.
As Johnny takes Clara for his wife, and promisesto protect her in sickness and in health, little
does he realize that she had lived with open
tuberculous in
the household. Whether or not she has escaped
its attack remains to be seen.
Their friends are equally ignorant of what
is going on in the Borik household. They can
see only the beautiful bride, and the dashing,
handsome groom. Two
healthy, vigorous young people who are now
man and wife.
Back at the Borik household, usually somber
and quiet, the Boriks and their guests gather
for a wedding festivity. Everyone has visited
and paid his respects
to Peter Borik in his sick room [background
comments].
Preparations are made to have the bride cut
the wedding cake.
Little does the happy couple suspect that
this ceremony is the backdrop for the tragedy
that is to follow.
But Johnny and Clara are unaware of the danger,
as they take over the operation of the Borik
farm where they now live. His life with Clara
is a happy one.
One day, more than a year after their marriage,
Johnny comes home from the fields to find
that Clara is not feeling well. He questions
her and finds she is
suffering from headaches, becomes fatigued
easily and is running a slight fever.
Clara then tells him she is going to have
a baby. And Johnny attributes the illness
to the coming child.
But as time goes on, Johnny wonders, could
it be that in some mysterious manner, Peter's
disease might be causing Clara's illness?
Clara's symptoms grow more evident daily.
She tires easily. The fresh farm foods cannot
tempt her appetite.
Johnny has made a decision. He is no longer
satisfied with Peter's advice that Clara eat
lots of food and stay out in the fresh air.
Johnny wants Clara to go to a competent doctor.
He fears for her life and that of their child.
Clara has just had an x-ray of her lungs,
and a physical
examination for tuberculosis at the sanatorium.
The x-ray film seen in the viewer reveals
she has fallen victim to the disease. The
sanatorium doctor explains that everyone should
have a chest x-ray each
year.
He tells Mrs. Borik that tuberculosis is not
inherited and it is not caused by weak lungs.
He points out that it's spread by germs from
one person to another
and it runs 15 times higher in families where
there is a history of tuberculosis.
The doctor ponders. He wonders where Clara
could have contracted tuberculosis.
He tells Mrs. Borik that one does not have
to look sick to be sick with tuberculosis.
The doctor also points out that the earlier
tuberculosis is detected,
the easier the disease is to cure.
The body must build up a resistance to the
germ. Clara has far advanced tuberculosis.
If she'd only come to a doctor earlier...
If she'd only been checked periodically for
tuberculosis...How, he asked Mrs. Borik, could
Clara have caught tuberculosis?
Mrs. Borik knows now. Sadly she recites the
story of Peter for the first time. Peter,
her husband, was in a sanatorium for treatment.
But Peter didn't like the sanatorium. He didn't
feel sick. He didn't realize that he should
be willing to remain hospitalized so that
his family would be
protected against the disease.
He didn't believe what the doctors told him.
One night, Peter left the sanatorium. Peter
Borik left the sanatorium against medical
advice.
The full impact of Peter's willfulness; his
persistent rejection of the truth, has come
home. Johnny wants Clara to go to the sanatorium.
He feels that both her life and the life of
their child might be saved. He knows if she'd
gone earlier, she would not have to stay so
long in the sanatorium.
But Peter has taught his lesson well.
Clara too rejects sanatorium care. She will
take her chances of getting well at home.
Her father had told her that once you enter
the sanatorium, you would
surely die.
Poor Clara. She believes this wrong advice.
What better attention could she get in a sanatorium?
she asks herself and her husband.
But she has no way of telling if she is getting
better or worse. At the sanatorium she would
be x-rayed regularly.
Sputum tests would be taken. Surgery would
be recommended if necessary. The progress
of her disease would be noted regularly.
Johnny begs Clara again to go to a sanatorium.
Complicated by the fact that she is expecting
a baby, tuberculosis works quickly in Clara.
She loses ground
rapidly.
Tuberculosis takes its toll. And with Clara's
death, another life is taken. The life of
her unborn child.
Clara has paid with her life. Johnny is not
very expressive, but he misses Clara terribly.
They had had so little time together. None
of their plans, the
plans of youth, had come to fruition.
He remembers her vivacity. Her winsome smile.
Her dark curls. And her tender touch.
He realizes that all this is lost to him forever
because of a disease which need not have happened
if it had not been for one man's willfulness.
And in remembering Clara and her youth, he
thinks of Agnes, who has gone to work in a
factory. Will the pattern of tragedy be repeated
in lively Agnes, who
has such a desire to live?
Johnny has talked to the tuberculosis worker.
She has urged Johnny to prevail upon Agnes
to have a chest x-ray.
She pointed out to Johnny that tuberculosis
takes its greatest toll among young people
from 15 to 35 years of age. Johnny tells Agnes
this. He asks her to
have an x-ray.
After all, he reasons, if you find out that
you haven't caught tuberculosis from your
father or Clara, you have nothing to worry
about.
If you do find out you have tuberculosis,
you can go to the sanatorium before your case
becomes hopeless. He tells her that many people
have the tuberculosis
germ in their bodies.
As long as the resistance is kept up, the
germ remains inactive. He tells Agnes she
has been working hard at her factory job,
that the germ may have gotten a
foothold in her body.
He reasons with her. But Agnes can't be reasoned
with. She has a streak of her father's willfulness
in her. It is fate, she decides.
If my father was sick with tuberculosis, and
my sister died from it, I will too. It's just
a matter of time and I might as well enjoy
life.
Secretly, Agnes feels that she too might have
the disease.
Many thousands of tuberculous sick are among
us. Everything they touch, cough, or spit
on is infected with the tuberculosis germ.
They're a constant source of danger to the
people who come in contact with them. But
they go blithely on their way, either unaware
that they have the
disease, or unwilling to do anything about
it.
Agnes is afraid. She does not want to know
the truth.
But the truth cannot be denied and shut out
forever. It must come out. And Agnes, despite
her stubbornness, cannot refuse to acknowledge
that she is sick.
Too sick to work efficiently.
Many industries have case-finding programs.
Industry wants to protect its workers against
tuberculosis.
An x-ray is painless and takes only a moment.
X-ray is used to find tuberculosis among apparently
healthy people as well as among persons who
have had contact with a tuberculosis patient.
They find her disease in the factory x-ray.
And, as is true in industry, when tuberculosis
is found, she is required to leave her work.
Agnes has tuberculosis. No longer does Mrs.
Borik need to be convinced. Tuberculosis killed
one daughter, and she is determined to save
Agnes.
Mrs. Borik will defy Peter at any cost. Knowing
that his ignorance has caused this tragedy,
she is going to have a chest x-ray herself.
Johnny will have one
too.
Agnes has finally reconciled to going to the
sanatorium. She sees that her father is not
getting any better at home, and that Clara
came home only to die.
She realizes that if she gives up six months
of time now to sanatorium treatment, she may
well save her life.
Happily, Agnes' disease has been caught early.
She will be able to recover from tuberculosis,
and lead a happy, normal life.
She now realizes tuberculosis can be cured.
It is not a death sentence.
Mrs. Borik knows, and Johnny knows, that by
going to the sanatorium early, Agnes' chances
for recovery are enhanced.
Johnny and Mrs. Borik return to their house
of sorrow, determined that there shall be
no more needless suffering and death. They
have been examined, and they
happily are not victims of Peter's disease.
It will not be a simple matter to return Peter
to a sanatorium, but their minds are made
up. They know he is wrong in staying home.
He must go back to the
tuberculosis hospital.
Last year, more than 50,000 American men,
women and children died in our country, because
they made the wrong decisions when they still
could have been
saved.
Don't let the tragedy of the Borik family
repeat in your home! Remember, no home is
safe until all homes are safe.
[Music]
[The End, A Capital Film Production.]